I'm at the Dead Sea the Dead Sea is
1,300 feet below sea level it's the
lowest point on earth the water is so
salty it is literally impossible to sink
and yet they have a lifeguard Wow
my body changing all the salts my penis
has been turned into a grind Vlasic
pickles be honest tonight you white yeah
right - white are you here with your
boyfriend no okay you're with me now I
took off my wedding ring they said you
can't wear jewelry here I'm not married
while I'm in the Dead Sea why are you
covered in this mud you think methyl the
Dead Sea because the old those minerals
and stuff and you put it all over your
body
yeah is it subtractive do I look at
wracked ofnow attractive Israeli man
more attractive than without them I know
so you think I'm more attractive covered
in mud then as God made me I'm gonna go
that way and then cry yes get a glass of
red wine and 600 glasses of water
[Music]
[Applause]
you